blackish star miles Brown is hoping for
Mirabeau Glory on Dancing with the Stars
juniors mouths telling me he was born
dance so you are a good dancer you've
taken some dance lessons before has that
helped you at all in dancing stars I've
been dancing like my whole life I wasn't
doing this certain styles of it yes so I
met it's pretty much new still the 13
year old nailed it on night 1 scoring a
22 out of 30 and tying for second place
we've seen miles dancing skills before
and he's been known to bust a move on
blackish have you asked Anthony or Tracy
about advice of how to steal the show no
well I for sure won't ask Anthony I know
that Tracy can dance
JC could dance and so can miles this
junior pro partner Riley their mentor
mayor ball champ and Riley's big sis
Lindsey Arnold is your sister of
Bossypants
yes but the biggest challenge for this
little duo is trying to keep a straight
face these two I love them but they
cannot be serious yeah they have a
really hard time laughing it's like it's
done we have a lot of giggles they're
children so they
[Music]